every esport has superstars but only a
few have gods
and a crouch
stuff this could be it
this is
[Applause]
in super smash bros melee the pantheon
stands for competitive excellence but
not all gods hold the same values
[Music]
mango
that's disrespectful to everyone
maylie's most beloved god isn't
calculating or distant he's a master of
the game but he's also the spirit of the
game that's what you get losing to mango
on land yeah that's what this is about
the well-deserved
victory
[Laughter]
there may be other gods but only one of
them has the most devoted following and
there will only ever be one mango
[Applause]
[Music]
joseph marquez grew up on the u.s west
coast in norwalk california his home
life meant that he moved around
frequently but the one constant in his
life was gaming well i've been playing
video games since
since as long as i can remember my mom
always got us this system she always let
me i think because it was a lot like
gang life out here so i think it's
better he was fascinated with sports
playing melee with his friends and
counter-strike which is where he made a
joke that eventually became his lifelong
moniker so we're at the land center i
was really hungry i changed my name to i
wanted mango because mangoes my favorite
fruit to this day my friend was there i
think his name was johnny actually
and the next day i would show up hey
what's up mango and then for whatever
reason like
from that day forward everyone just
called me mango mango quickly realized
that he was a gifted melee player and
the world learned just how good he was
at evo 2007 where he beat mewtwo king
one of the best players in the world
[Applause]
while he didn't go all the way mango
finished a respectable third place
behind melee powerhouses ken and hugs
and mango kept going he proved that he
wasn't a fluke with a follow up third
place at super champ combo and then
cemented his position by winning pound
three after a legendary losers run
[Music]
i was trying to lose in losers but i
couldn't lose like i was just playing
and i would try to lose and i would just
win
and then i got the ad
now mango was clearly one of the best
melee players in the world the question
was whether that would be worth anything
in the long run whether melee would
stick around the release of super smash
bros brawl in 2008 threatened melee's
competitive lifespan and 2009's revival
of melee tournament brought the greatest
melee players on the planet together to
try to keep the game alive and the
greatest among them was once again mango
oh
[Music]
the beginning of the five gods era
showed melee wasn't dead it was just
starting a new journey one that finally
took the game to an international stage
genesis 1 was the first time when
america's best and europe's best were
finally playing against each other for
the first time the feel that genesis
featured armada europe's best player
mango himself wasn't sure he could win
he he was beating everybody
and he
and he actually turned to me and he said
i can't do it
like he he thought he was done my goal
was just to convince him that he could
still do it but he did and along the way
he gave us one of the wildest reads in
melee history
everyone's yelling it's so hyped
up
by january 2010 with an incredible
victory over hungrybox at pound four
it was clear mango was the best melee
player in the world mango
that's disrespectful to everyone
[Applause]
now atop the standings mango did what
any reasonable person in his position
would do he created an alter ego and
started playing exclusively bad
characters sitting next to me i got the
two-in-one deal i got the most
interesting man in life
we were saying it today on the stream
this is the man who invented the
invention scorpio master aka scorpio
dwarf aka mango
say what's up to the people sir
what's up
for a year mango played as scorpion
master an alias devised a dinner as a
joke after dropping a set to silent
spectre and norcal falcon player socal
went deep into it yeah yeah i guess
he rode with it like yeah went back home
made an account called scorpio because
he got banned on smash bros yeah yeah
man it's going to be a master account
super humble
my name's josh
that was like the total opposite of
mango like whatever mango is just think
yeah this is yang and to mangoes
the name and character choices like
mario stuck for a little while but he
was still mango and mango isn't exactly
known for staying humble you play any
pools yet yeah i finished my pull in
like four seconds
and sure manga was just trolling but he
revealed something important he showed
the world a quieter humbler mango who
didn't strive to be the best he showed
the world what melee was missing out on
without mango
and it only made the community love him
even more
by the end of 2012 mango reasserted
himself as a dominant melee player now
playing fox and falco that continued
into 2013 and he couldn't have started
taking melee seriously again at a better
time because in 2013 melee returned to
evo and being at the biggest fighting
game tournament in the world
helped melee explode in popularity evo
2013 was for many young smashers their
first glimpse of melee and what they saw
was a single god above all others
oh nice down a to save himself just with
that one situation but still
and there it is the up smash mango was
popular at just the right moment but he
didn't rest on his laurels after a short
break following the birth of his son he
kept winning both in game and out almost
that's
rom 7 is over as melee at army's very
own mango takes it home
air forward smash
misses with the lasers and holding gonna
get a chance with the [ __ ] that is the
tournament
congratulations to mango
like google with cloud9 i saw like the
blue there's the blue shirt with the
white jerseys or the white sweaters and
then the logo and i'm like i'm down i
was just like right there i was like
yeah this is sick and he didn't stop
there oh my god
wow wow wow all right third another
level but the firefox almost gave an
opportunity for him to convert
oh man this is good and that is a
destruction
can mango close it out for c9 or can
armada take this to a game five oh my
god
this shield is almost gone there it is
that's it in the back here mango takes
the tournament wow
he can't trade he cannot trade and make
gold why not take it yet he goes for the
upper throw up here this time it hits
and we have our champion mango
first place here at evolution 2014 for
super smash brothers
melee the crowds alive we're living will
this be the last game in the big house
or will we go to game five and the
recovery four they're so smart
oh my god
he upbears mako beats mewtwo king
mango takes the big house
out of fuji king's arms with his
historic 2014 there was little question
mango was the greatest melee player of
all time
it wasn't just mango's success at
tournaments that made him popular though
he was bigger than his results and no
part of mango was bigger than his
persona yes i am you're not going i am
you're so dumb you're not i'm not dumb
you're dumb
you're dumb you're dumb you think i'm
dumb you're dumb
you're definitely dumber than me no
you're taller than me no not even close
is that your sister oh my god
baby uh
i think he's leaving soon the baby's
leaving soon he loves this microphone so
much after his 2013 evo win mango
started streaming and his twitch blew up
shout outs to bobby scar um he was like
dude you got to stream you got to stream
he's like you have the personality for
it i promise you people will love you
[Music]
oh my god
come on
come on
come on
come on baby come on come on
oh let's go
let's go
it's not hard to see why mango got so
big beyond his skill he was a kid from
norwalk who had climbed up the ladder
with his own brand of melee specifically
manga was the kind of player who wanted
to give his opponent no room to breathe
while taking as much space as possible
for himself i've seen so many of those
he's
right after he double jumped he realized
that mango was going straight down and
try to cover that yeah
these
conversions oh my god
[Applause]
oh
my god that's it that's mango
mango was also pretty upfront about his
opinions and didn't pull verbal punches
to some this came across as authentic
and natural for others it was abrasive
mango had pride because melee was worth
playing he had an ego because he was
clearly one of the best at it and he had
fans
because they loved that about him
mango mango mango mega mango
and as his career continued despite all
the extra attention on him
mango never stopped being mango
oh one time
i got him oh my god
on twitch and in the bracket mango was
on top but that wouldn't last for long
by 2015 melee was changing as the scene
got bigger more and more players were
coming for mango's throne at apex 2015
mango issued a challenge to leffen the
swedish smasher who was developing a
reputation as a godslayer
and he lost
yeah if he does this man up till not
gonna oh yes it is
what of all the ways for the set to end
and
life is this crazy
mystical thing
and sometimes you just go out like a
buster
and there's nothing you can do about it
i think everyone i want you to think
about your life how many times have you
gone on a bus it happens to everyone
yeah i went out like such a buster this
weekend
holy moly
act like mr cool guy on on saturday i
call it left him oh
and then i just get three to one
that attitude would serve mango well he
had to have a positive outlook about
losing because
as the years went on old opponents came
back to haunt him and his days of
winning any tournament he attended came
to an end that could have been the match
it's not good it's a bad spot for mango
mango
oh no not like this oh not like this
he's having trouble wrapping this up
that's a wrap
mango
oh
rest it's over hungrybox wins he double
eliminates mango and takes packs arena
make a moment here oh
wow
is that gonna do it kills him off the
top with up air
hbox takes it yeah the days of constant
grand finals appearances at major
tournaments were gone by 2018. sure he
always made top eight but first and
second place grew more and more distant
as the decade drew to a close the
constant losses began affecting mango's
mental game too he dropped out of super
smash con 2018 after an early loss
giving him a 65th place finish that
divided the community some mango fans
were angry with the decision while
others simply cranked the mango fandom
up to incredible levels but those die
hard fans kept being tested with loss
after loss
okay here's the opening for mango
looking for something no jump yep wow
love sneaking out in there oh my word
and
that will do it look call out club so
very content just stay on stage and keep
nearing them off oh and the nair is that
actually it
that's actually it
popping up 3-0 mango oh man after a
two-year drought it seemed like manga
was done sure he was still the goat but
in this new era of melee it seemed like
he didn't have what it took to thrive to
be the best but then when it all seemed
hopeless
mango gave the true believers their
ultimate reward this might be it
there it is
get on my level 2019
champion
by the end of 2019 manga was a top three
player once again the mango nation had
the goat back but the teeming crowds of
melee majors were about to give way to
online play mango's stream was already
popular and the online era gave him a
chance to focus more on that i heard
that neith was really fun to play
there's a couple characters that oh
[ __ ] hell yeah like neve i can live i
can live
oh oh
[Laughter]
and while online tournaments weren't
ideal mango did play in plenty and he
was arguably more consistent than he was
offline
[Music]
yes it's over
but mango had always been the hometown
hero the crowd favorite he needed that
crowd behind him and they needed to see
him win for real
so when he returned to his first
in-person event smash summit 11
featuring the game's biggest ever
singles prize pool the pressure was on
he doesn't even go for dash attack
one last chance
he's still living
oh no he's too far away
the goat was sent to loser's side early
and he was ready to quit but he had made
these runs before
and somehow he did it again until all
that stood between him and glory was
zayn zayn was a huge foil to mango
before the online era and during it both
zayn and mango were neck and neck for
the title of na's best melee player
beating zayn here would re-cement
mango's status as the goat prove that no
one could question his skills that
despite all the years and all the losses
mango would not bust her out when it
mattered most
is this oregon unplugged no he's there
he's there he's there his feet get still
with another lead
oh
no chance that mango just stands to
charge up smashing his face from mango
oh yo
yo he's cooking he's cooking he's doing
this just listen to brandon
we got a reset
okay that's a stop
one [ __ ] away
[Applause]
this is the new rivalry
uh
he has finally done it
mango did it
winning smash summit 11 was the welcome
back party that his faithful needed it
was proof that no matter what the haters
said manga was still the best player in
the world
minus 2008 to 2021
and guess what only player to win majors
in three different decades
three
taking three characters to the top three
three
the youngest and oldest player to win
the super major that's me
that's me
and while the win was important it's
clear that mango is more than just his
competitive achievements he's the goat
but he's also the hometown hero the huge
personality the drunken master and he
refuses to compromise on who he is they
stopped selling beer at like
10 10 10 a.m or something on a sunday i
tweeted i was like hey
can somebody pleased me welcome in the
back of the stage and i [ __ ] you not
i [ __ ] you not
it looked like a one direction fan me
just
lines and lines of people
mango found his path in melee and his
journey inspired thousands more to play
the game i always said i could never
retire because like manly literally gave
me everything in my life so it's like
i feel like i have a debt to bailey that
like i can't pay off he might not be
perfect and sometimes
he still goes out like a buster tell me
i'm a sore loser i was losing before any
machete was even born before a kid from
norwalk who probably never thought it
would get to this point it's hard to
imagine him doing anything else but this
and uh we're getting [ __ ] up i'm
getting so black
tonight
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you